how is your baby boy he is a little
angel I'm so obsessed with him he's like
my whole heart feels so full I feel like
my life is so complete now
now
it's so cute
is it true that you kept this one to
yourself
because why
I just feel that my life has been so
public and I just wanted this for myself
I didn't want to have to deal with the
media and people online talking about my
son before that he came onto this world
safe and healthy and happy
so you did it your way why do you think
that this was so different
feel that this is a whole new phase in
my life
and even with his name Phoenix I feel
like this is all about
transforming and just becoming a new
person and growing in ways that I
couldn't even imagine before
I know I don't I don't know at like
certain intervals of both of our lives
that have intersected over all the like
good the naughty the bad the fun like
all of it in fact I like
I was looking at pictures this morning
here we here we are this is one point in
our life okay that's you literally
walking out of jail
all right there's me partying they've
had to black out the cigarettes that's
me at nine smoking partying
you know I know funny sad weird like all
of the above here we are party girls yes
God that was fun so much fun so much fun
oh my God the most fun people don't know
what fun is today like I feel like they
really don't know it's so different and
then
you know you're watching this Evolution
look at us now
that's you in front of the White House
you know being an advocate here I am
interviewing the president and first
lady
we're so grown up
[Applause]
you continue to peel back the curtain
why do you do that
ever since my documentary it was the
first time that I really got real
and I've just been on this whole path of
self-discovery because I was just my
life was moving so fast and I had been
some through so much trauma that I never
had a moment to just think about
everything and the past couple years
have just been just so empowering and I
just feel like I finally know who I am
how do people be themselves and be brave
about it the everything the whole stew
I think that people should know that
they are not their trauma and to not
hold on to shame that should be put on
the person that hurt them I think that's
a really important message in my book
especially
and I feel that
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
for sure because I've been through hell
and back and now I'm in the best place
in my life and I just feel so grateful
every single day so it's okay to like
Embrace everything yes you know and now
we're both parents by the way what's it
like having a boy I love it everyone
always say that the boys love the mom so
much so I could just tell already just
stares at me anytime I walk in he hears
my voice it just he lights up it just
so cute I'm so obsessed but I can't wait
to have a daughter too
oh that whole mother-daughter thing oh
my God second I found out I was having a
girl I was like no Karma here we go
although you have a boy I have two girls
like I just found out about something
called the pptp do you use one of those
when you change his diapers yeah for
boys you need it you need it I love
babies I love it I was like you hold
them up for a long time so they don't
spill out all the milk you just finally
got in them and the tummy training and
the core build up and the Sleep patterns
and you know like all of it like what is
one of your favorite Parts my favorite
is every single night he just lays on my
chest we do skin to skin and it's just
this bonding experience and he's just
like
I don't notice it feels just this love
that I've never experienced before
I just
fell in love with him and another man in
your life as you write in the book with
your husband and like
is it true you were diagnosed with ADHD
yes
um and that your husband how has he
worked with you and handled that
differently he's just so kind and so
supportive and patient and he just
lifts me up in ways that no man ever has
he has actually been talking to Dr
Hollowell who's my ADHD doctor and he
has just been researching and just knows
so much about it now so he just he knows
probably more about it than most people
and is it true that you're like you have
five phones and there's a reason for
that yes why well one is for business
one's for friends one's for Europe
one's for people and I feel bad that
when they ask for my number and I don't
want to say nothing so I give him that
number and then the last one is for
prank calls
that you make to other people yes shut
up what is a Paris Hilton prank phone
call please it's mostly my mom
she's the one who taught me and she is
so good at it like we have parties at
the house and then everyone will end up
in the done and we'll just be prank
calling people for hours who have you
pranked